how long are you going to wait
I'm sorry
before you ask me what you want to ask
me
a few days
a few weeks must have taken you months
to work your way in here
you're more patient than I am I don't
know what you're talking about don't lie
to me boy
I remember you
I'm tired of alone
you watched those women parade me
through the streets like an animal you
must be confused
I can see it when another man can tell
there's a glow and it's yours
yours was brighter than any I've ever
seen
I'll never forget looking up and seemed
you're sitting up that wall I knew you'd
shake the world Kate's as I was I
couldn't help lie
and here you are now all these months
later all these miles away
so ask me
you came here for
[Music]
I want to know
how to control them
foreign